being irresistible and confident on
camera it does not come naturally to
most of us you know hitting that record
button can be terrifying and it could be
one of the biggest obstacles holding us
back and I know this from experience I
know what it feels like to have
self-doubt and the fear of messing up
not sounding right or even feeling
judged I've been there and I can tell
you it gets easier over time creating
video after video you start to learn how
to be confident in your message and you
learn how to really just punch fear in
the face and press report so I'm so
excited to share this episode with you
where Sean sits down with Stephanie Lou
she's one of our groweth video live
speakers this year and she's going to
help you master your presence and power
on camera so you can get those videos
published
welcome to the pink marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm your host Heather Torres and I'm
Sean Connell and we are from think media
and if this is your first time listening
we appreciate you being here and want to
say thank you this show is dedicated to
helping you get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies that
are working right now online so whether
you want to grow a YouTube channel or
you want to maximize video across all of
social media this is for you hey welcome
back to the think marketing podcast I am
here with Stephanie Liu from lights
camera action one of our speakers this
year at groweth video live and she's
gonna be breaking down how to be
irresistible on camera and how we can
actually build more confidence and have
more impact on camera Stephanie how's it
going good how are you I'm fired up I'm
sweaty because I scooted over here and
realized this was a no scooter area
I couldn't park it so I had to go miles
further down the road to park it and
come back oh did you walk farther than
you scoot it I walked farther than I
scooted sweating having to find a place
to drop it off and it was a slow speed
zone so I had to go like four miles not
12
yeah even get further away to walk all
the way back which has nothing to do
with this podcast but it's a great story
of pain suffering person
Varun's its determination and
determination determined to come here
yeah absolutely but hey if people are
just meeting you we're so pumped that
you're coming to grow a video live and
about how you're helping entrepreneurs
and people build their business with
live video and streaming content a lot
of different things what's kind of how
you what's your back story in a nutshell
and how you ended up doing what you do
today doing video oh goodness
well so I'm an ad agency veteran I spent
the last stick and a half deep in the
trenches of agency life and when I got
pregnant and I realized man I can't work
50 plus hours a week if I'm gonna have
another human being I had to separate
myself from the sea of sameness and so
the best way to do that you guys know
this was to embrace video because when
you do video you become top of mind and
tip of tongue so once I started doing
live video write something that people
are so scared of doing but for some
reason like that's how I started getting
new clients like after every single
broadcast boom new client boom in
another one and so I only go live twice
a month which is crazy because some
people push out to videos twice a week
and they're like hustling but you know
just to live videos and I get the
retainer clients that's so powerful and
you're here and we're recording this at
an event San Diego and your talks gonna
be on actually how to get on camera and
be more powerful and maybe break down at
first
I mean you've helped so many different
clients and so many different people
that is the thing to overcome I mean how
do you punch fear in the face how do you
get on camera what are people gonna
think how are people gonna judge me am I
gonna sound right all those different
things before we get into your three
tips what is kind of just some initial
mindset and some things you've learned
about helping overcome people overcome
that fear well okay so it's the funny
thing when it comes to video people
think that okay if I'm gonna do a video
thousands and thousands of people are
going to watch me but in reality it's
that one person that's playing that
video on their phone or on the computer
so to them to them it feels like it's a
one-to-one interaction and the more that
they actually see you I don't know if
you guys know this but when you see
someone and you look in their eyes your
brain naturally starts to release
oxytocin which is that happy brain
chemical so the more that they watch the
videos the more rapport that they have
with you that's why when people like see
Sean they're like oh my god I know you
right they're absolutely in love with
you
that's so powerful okay well what's tip
number one then for how we can start
being more powerful on cameras yes okay
so the first thing that I usually tell
people is learn how to do anchoring and
anchoring is actually an NLP technique I
don't know if you've actually ever
studied NLP it stands for neuro
linguistic programming I don't think
I've studied it but I know a little bit
about it yeah yeah so it's one of those
things where working with clients I say
think of a time when you felt the most
confident the most powerful the most
resourceful because that's the exact
state that you want to be in when you're
doing your videos because here's the
thing you guys
there is a difference between real
happiness and fake happiness and that
shows on camera so if you could actually
use NLP to be confident on demand
whenever you want wherever you go
whatever stage you're on then that's
what's been really gonna make that in so
this is a way of kind of activating your
confidence by going back to a time when
you felt confident yes so is this kind
of like taking a moment to close your
eyes kind of become present and just
think about that how do you kind of get
into the and what do you do you're about
to speak what are you gonna do before
you speak okay so this this is gonna be
really kind of funny but the anchor that
I have is actually on my wrist right
here so if you've ever seen me behind
the stage I actually like hit my wrist
because I have all my positive resource
anchors in here so the time that I
sealed the deal with my first client the
time that I crushed it on stage
all of those memories are all locked in
here and when you actually create a
stimulus to an emotional state you the
two of them become neurologically linked
together so neuroscientists have this
saying that neurons that fire together
wire together so if you could just
trigger it like a light switch now
that's so powerful it's super powerful
yeah I love it okay well what's tip
number two so tip number two is the
genius of gestures right so weaving hi
to the camera I don't know if you guys
know this but most people when they
start doing video right they're like I
don't know what to do with my hands and
sometimes they'll hide it they'll put it
in their pocket but that actually
triggers the amygdala in our brain and
that's the part of the brain that
actually processes fear so if you're
actually hiding your hand
you're actually telling your viewer they
shouldn't trust you Wow so whenever I do
a live video it's always like hey what's
up welcome to lights camera live this is
what the show is going to be about so
it's that Universal sign of of openness
that you want to do in your videos and
even if you're doing an interview like I
always tell my guests like wave height
weight hello yeah yeah that's really
powerful and you know I think about that
same tip from being a videographer I've
realized even moving your hands and this
is kind of a balance I'd love your take
on this moving your hands and what not
can be a way of keeping people engaged
it's you know just your hand movements
in general but also and if you're
listening on the podcast you can't see
this but if you're on YouTube you know
I'll do things one video where you'll
uncover the camera or you'll move your
hand closer to the camera and it's these
types of signals I can keep people
engaged so I love the fact that you
could wave or really emphasize something
but that makes sense if you hide your
hands that's sending a message as well
so really you're kind of having us think
through the visual cues and these visual
cues actually carry power to hold
retention in our video and create
connection yeah there's actually there's
this fascinating study at the science of
people where they studied the most
successful TEDx talks and they found
that the most viral TEDx talks are the
ones that actually use more gestures and
when I talk about gestures I'm not
talking about just moving your hands
like all crazy some people call it being
Italian I totally get that but when you
use your gestures powerfully and with
impact then people know like okay that's
the important thing that I need to take
note of and write that down so that's
another tip for you guys man I love that
and I'm excited for tip number three but
I definitely want to remind you think
community that if you haven't your
tickets for growth video live yet go
ahead and grab those growth video
live.com definitely Lou's gonna be one
of our speakers there as well as so many
other great speakers that you can see
and we're gonna be mastering these types
of things I mean that's what it's all
about is it's about our camera presence
it's about our scripting and what we say
in our videos it's about the technical
side it's about the tactical side of SEO
and and knowing what kind of content
where LinkedIn video Facebook live
Instagram live Instagram video all of
the things are going down and grow with
video so growth video live.com make sure
to grab your two
get and Stephanie what's tip number
three though for how we can power up our
on camera president so this is this is
actually a secret I don't think most
people know this but there's a lot that
you could do with spatial anchoring so
knowing how people process information
if you want them to remember stuff
knowing that when they recall
information they usually recall on this
side so if I want you to remember
something I'm gonna put it on this side
of the screen because that's where
they're gonna remember it so for those
listening what is this side versus that
side in terms of left or right so if I
were to ask you what color was your room
when you're growing up yes is blue okay
so most people when they're thinking or
they're recalling information they kind
of look up and to the left as they're
thinking about it okay guys
how that's useful when you're actually
doing a video is if you want to put a
call to action you have to think of it's
gonna be reverse because for me it's
looking up into the left the audience if
I'm showing them something yeah I'm
gonna put the call-to-action up into the
right so that way they remember it
gotcha
if I want them to imagine what it would
be like to buy my product or my service
or to work with me I want to activate
their imagination I'm always gonna put
it on this side of the screen which is
like to the left
sure to the left of me but that you were
will see it to the right exactly so
knowing how the brain works and
basically what you're doing is that
you're locking in that information
unconsciously to them and you're using
how you're like the whole space you're
using that space consciously in a
strategic way I love it well final
question and it's so powerful that
you're breaking out all these like
psychological types of things and this
is the stuff that matters you know
especially when you think about if you
think about copywriting which is really
the foundation of video is understanding
just how the brain works how to get
attention and even what to be doing
visually so I love that you're gonna be
breaking out more of this stuff I grow a
video live but I just want to have your
take in 2020 what are you excited about
you're spending most of your time on
Facebook live and in groups what do you
see happening specifically with Facebook
video live video groups things like that
a lot of what I've been hearing on the
ground really as far as like live video
is the multi streaming a lot of people
are trying to tap into multi streaming
across platforms which i think is
brilliant and you have
tools like stream yard that will allow
you to do that some of the other people
that have like wire cast sure now lets
up they do that but I would say if
you're just getting into the game stream
yard is super helpful yeah that Perot
account allows you to do five locations
my team and I were just talking about it
because we were thinking about well if
we really want to do something that's
like a big announcement or like a big
you know yeah that's impact it's like a
blitz marketing cabbage blitz market
that's really yeah yeah it's a blitz
marketing campaign you touch them
wherever they are and they're gonna find
you and streamer is so easy to use and
so of course we'll always think those
resources up in the show notes and
streamlines been a lot of fun we've been
using instead of our inner circle
program and for some other training that
we've been doing and you know I was just
at 10x conference program cardones
conference in Vegas and he actually had
Donald Trump's and it was one of the
most powerful sessions because Facebook
about the campaign not being political
here but they Facebook own admission
that it was was that it was the best
Facebook campaign politically ever run
that they ran for that campaign and the
best Facebook campaign in any industry
in history ever run they spent a quarter
million dollars and between now and the
election they're gonna spend a billion
dollars towards reelection but the
takeaway there and of course were such
big YouTube fans we're such were super
big Instagram fans but the takeaway was
actually you know they've got this huge
agency that they run and his campaign
manager he said that Facebook has the
most eyeballs of any platform in the
world yeah period yeah more than YouTube
more than any television more than any
sporting event more than anything at all
that Facebook has the most so when I
think about this that's why it's so
important to be learning for people like
you and I think there's the power of
focus like it's really hard when you're
just starting to run a YouTube channel
and a Facebook page and a lot of other
things but we need to be asking thing
community how can we be taking massive
action on Facebook to tapping into the
power of groups tapping into the power
of paid ads and tapping into the power
of more eyeballs more of your target
customers
than ever are on Facebook and I love
that you said focus because the acronym
that we have is focus on completion
until successful and that's what it is
about being focused because there are
different platforms that are out there
but once you master it and you know the
inner workings behind it it's just like
pulling a lever and you're like boom
let's go wow I really loved all of those
tips that Stephanie just gave in that
interview yeah I mean Stephanie's
awesome and I think just the idea of
building your confidence on camera is
something that we have to realize is
something that takes time I mean it's
it's kind of like riding a bike and
you're gonna fall off at first and it's
gonna be awkward at first and you're
going to have to continue to practice
but practice makes progress and you know
when people see I think you're powerful
on camera you're powerful on stage
people you know will say Shawn you
disappear confident on camera and I'm
like bro sis I've published and posted
over 2,000 videos online I grew up in
the church where they like made me do
announcements and stand in front of
people and I would share sermons in the
early days that were terrible you know I
mean they were just they were horrendous
but that was all time to practice in
2009 when I started my business clear
vision media I would go to Chamber of
Commerce and stand up in front of other
bankers and painters and talk about my
business which was not just a business
opportunity it was a chance for me to
present myself present my vision state
my tagline or lack thereof state my
mission statement but all of that is
what made me into the communicator that
I am today and helped me develop the
confidence that I have today so I just
want to encourage you you got to just
press record and you got to do it over
and over again as Heather says you got
to start messy ready is a lie and then
you got to do it a lot and you got to do
it over and over and over again but
what's crazy is you want to plant the
seeds today for the harvest that you
want to reap tomorrow yes we want you to
get results in your business with video
next week and next month but really what
we're doing here at the think marketing
podcast is we're positioning and
preparing ourselves to be having power
YouTube channels powerful video podcasts
powerful content going out on LinkedIn
and on other of the top video platforms
Facebook and live-streaming
we're preparing ourselves now so that
we're ready for the even greater wave
that's coming social media is hot now
but it's even rising more and more
especially as we see crazy things
happening in culture disruptive
situations that are causing people to
have to stay home and that are just
disrupting education in the workplace
having an online business being
diversified to be able to livestream and
create content from home or your office
is so important and so now's the time to
punch fear in the face work on your
confidence and press record yes and I am
excited because Stephanie is actually
one of the speakers this year for grow
with video live and along with Stephanie
we have an entire lineup of speakers
yeah I can't wait for growth video live
go to grow with video live.com if you
haven't got your tickets yet you're
gonna find the best rates there as well
as see all the details about what you
can expect grow a video live is the
number one video marketing conference
for entrepreneurs and so if you've got a
dream a business a small business or
large business that you want to start
scaling and accelerating faster with
video then make sure you register yes
and right now it's the time to take
action you know we just learned about
pressing record we learned about the
confidence that we need to be gaining so
when are you gonna do it when's your
next video coming out that's what I want
you to do right now is write down when
are you going to take action you know
here at think media we want to make sure
that you are taking action and so pause
this write it down and we want to know
let us know in the comments if you're
watching on youtube or share on social
media when are you taking action for
your next video yes and of course we
also want to thank you for rating and
reviewing the podcast on Apple podcasts
we have the comment of the week this
week from Alicia teaches ESL and she
said this this podcast is a game-changer
I am so excited I have only just begun
following I can't wait to continue to
learn
grow by listening and applying these
golden nuggets of information in this
podcast Alisha thanks you so much for
that kind review and if you haven't
rated and reviewed the podcast yet
do us a favor if you've been getting
value from the content if you've been
enjoying watching this on YouTube or
listening on Spotify or Apple or Google
then head over to Apple podcasts rate it
review it and guess what we're actually
doing a giveaway of two tickets to grow
a video live.com grow a video live here
in Vegas and so to enter if you go to
think marketing show com there's a
couple details step-by-step of what you
need to do to get entered it only takes
a minute or so to do all the steps you
just write your review you'll see all
the details that's think marketing show
com if you want to be entered to win two
tickets just go to think marketing
show.com yeah and we just want to say
thank you thanks for being connected
here to us on the podcast thanks for
being along on this journey as we
started a podcast and we want you to
stay connected stay connected to
positive content like this that is out
on the internet and the way you can do
that is by clicking that red subscribe
button on YouTube or if you're listening
you can subscribe on any of the
podcasting platforms we want to
encourage you to take action it's so
important that you set yourself up for
success for tomorrow by doing the
actions today thanks for watching this
episode and we'll see you in the next
podcast